what's up guys my name is Samuel Leeds
and I'm property investor I get them
I've been asked a lot recently about
compliance legislation rules now I my
most thing that I'm bothered about is
making money you know I'm very good at
making money however I think of course
it's important that you're compliant and
that you're doing everything legal and
as I'm getting asked so much about that
I thought I'd bring some guests onto the
show and we have James Armstrong James
who what you would either
I'm James Armstrong I'm a deal sorcerer
and I've been induced about 18 months
now I'm doing so well making tens of
thousands of pounds a month actually
what's your speciality so I specialize
in Bari for every fine arts yeah and you
do a lot of joint ventures yeah joint
ventures raising finance bridging loans
the whole kaboodle how about you Hannah
and so I do rent to sa and I also saw
went to sa as well right so your and
your sister background I am yeah so
actually a property background so I used
to deal with mortgage repossessions and
things yeah yeah great so got all that
legal background stuff going on so as we
get asked so much about legalities and
things like that
we've been talking about the idea of
actually why don't you say what we're
gonna do so our idea is to to write a
book about compliance because we know
how important the topic is and it's
really just to address what is important
on the compliance of the different
sections what you need to know and so
it's sort of one-stop shop to make sure
that we've got all that information in
one place for you yeah because the thing
is there's so much conflicting advice on
this subject and there's also you know
we want to answer Anna I'm repeating
myself over and over I know with you
guys being kind of authorities in the
property industry with your legal
backgrounds and different things the
same questions are coming up again and
again
stuff like what contracts do we use for
rent to rents you know do we how do we
become compliant for a deal Saucer all
these types of questions
what illegal responsibilities as a
landlord what kind of tenancy agreements
do you need for tenants and and and the
thing is it's it's important but it's a
subject that in my opinion unless you've
actually got the deals unless you've
actually got the investors it doesn't
have it's not your problem right now but
it's still important so we want to
create a one-stop shop where by all the
legal legislation compliance questions
that we get can be put in one place into
one book written with the help of you
guys so okay questions then if you've
got questions we want to answer them in
the book so if you've got any legal
questions drop them below your questions
will become the content to the buck have
you guys got anything to add to that
James how you feel about this I'm
feeling really excited you know a lot of
people regula see it do I need a company
to invest in property it's like I say it
probably say that three or four times a
day like what people always ask me bill
sourcing what compliance need for deal
sourcing and there's so much content out
there and from the books at the moment
like that thick like 300 400 pages it's
far too long usually the checklist of
like this like 10 or 15 points saying do
this do this do this I want to make it
accessible and easy for people so when
you read it you can just go right I've
done it and you know that you're right
has been backed up everything's been
checked out already I think that's so
true
I think there's almost a lot of myths
going around as well sometimes people
make something more complicated than it
is just because they want to stop you
doing it so I think the great thing
about about you guys right and this is
it's like no agenda no axe to grind
yeah it's solutions not problems yeah
and and there's not gonna be like you
know to learn more about compliance you
need mentorship it's just everything
answered in this book best we can
yeah so what do you thinking Hannah no
actually when I first started there was
nothing out there I don't think there is
still anything out there that literally
has everything all in one place
like James Nancy said there's low loads
of people have got an opinion on it
and I've written books on it but to
literally have some things to sing it
all within the pages of one book it's
quite cool I know Tina waltz for a great
book about sourcing but what this is
gonna be is this isn't gonna be just on
sources this is going to be on all the
different aspects of props like a
checklist on every point and and how you
what you guys asked for is what we're
gonna write so epic man well guys thank
you so much I'm excited to read the book
myself
you're gonna write it we're then gonna
make it accessible to people and I hope
you hope you get it if you're gonna read
the book if you would be interested in
the book before we write it also drop a
comment if you want to read the book say
yes if you don't want to read the book
and you think it sounds like a terrible
idea
then come
no but if you're watching this you've
got a comment it also helps the YouTube
algorithm so thank you very much see you
next time
[Music]